To draw the last graph or the last several graphs I had to use a set of axis.
One for each variable we have in our equation. The standard way to set this up
is to label the horizontal axis the x axis. This demarcates how are x values
change. And the vertical axis is the y axis, showing how y values change. Now,
every point on this plane is associated with both a value in the horizontal
direction, an x value, and a value in the vertical direction, a y value. I also
mentioned earlier that we identify points on our coordinate plane with a special
notation. The first number listed is our x-coordinate, or our horizontal
position. And the second number in the ordered pair is the y-coordinate or the
vertical position of the point. The areas that you see on the ends of each axis
represent continuation, so the x axis continues all the way out to infinity and
also in the other direction, all the way out to negative infinity. And the same
is true of the y axis so this coordinate plane are really able to represent, if
we want to take as much time and paper as possible, any combination of 2 real
numbers. And then of course we can depict it graphically. There is 1 single
point on this graph however, 1 point out of that infinite number of points,
that's really special. And we call it the origin. Which point of all these ones
highlighted in teal do you think is special enough to have such an illustrious
title as the origin? Click where you think it is.